>>Dick: I'm Dick Soule. I work at YouTube
Global. It's my honor to introduce Eric Pooley.
Eric is the deputy editor of Bloomberg Businessweek.
He is the former managing editor of Fortune
and Chief Political Correspondent for Time
magazine. Eric's work has been recognized
with many awards and honors, including a 2001
National Magazine Award, the 1996 Gerald R.
Ford Prize for Distinguished Reporting on
the Presidency and four Henry R. Luce awards
from Time. And being a humble man that Eric
is, I could read many more awards, but let's
just have Eric up here. Thank you.
[applause]
>>Eric: Thanks Dick.
>>Dick: You're welcome.
>>Eric: Hi, thanks for coming out today. It's
great to be with you and I appreciate the
introduction, Dick. I walked in to Google
and I was asked if I'd been here before, and
we started talking about people that I knew
here, and then I turned around and saw an
old friend. So, that was nice. And as Dick
said, I'm Eric Pooley and I am the deputy
editor of Businessweek. That's not why I'm
here today. I'm here as the author of a new
book called "The Climate War." It's a book
about the struggle to get serious about climate
change in the United States at the federal
level. So, it's a tale of battling to pass
a mandatory declining cap on carbon emissions.
In the spring of 2007, I saw that the debate
was starting to shift from the science to
the politics; from whether climate change
is real, although some people still debate
that point, it's not really debatable, to
what we're gonna do about it. And I thought,
"Well, there's a book. How about a book about
the attempt to begin to get serious in this
country, which is, as you know, has lagged
the rest of the industrialized world in taking
the problem seriously and beginning to try
to address it through a declining cap on emissions."
Somewhat naively, I thought that if I tracked
this story from 2007 through to 2010, I might
be able to tell a story with a happy ending;
that I might be able to actually write a narrative,
because I wanted to write a political thriller
with the fate of the Earth hanging in the
balance and that by following the characters
at the heart of this debate, by embedding
with them, if you will, the way reporters
embedded with the soldiers in Iraq, but doing
it on all sides of the war that I would be
able to tell the story about how we turned
the corner and took just the first step to
start to get serious about reducing emissions.
But a funny thing happened on the way to the
signing ceremony. We didn't get serious about
it; we didn't pass a federal bill to reduce
our emissions and so the book became not just
a political thriller, but actually a murder
mystery. It became a who-done-it. It became
a book about all the forces that conspired
to kill climate action on the federal level.
And as I was working on it, I thought back
a lot of times to when I was a crime reporter
in New York in the 1980s. I worked at New
York Magazine and I wrote crime stories and
in those days, there was a homicide detective
named Marty Davin who was very famous for
showing up at the hospital after someone had
been shot on his turf and he would try to
intercept the victim, who would be laying
on a gurney out in the hallway, and Davin
would go up and lean over the guy and say,
"Who killed you?" And, which would tend to
get the attention of the victim if he was
indeed conscious and he would often protest,
"I'm not dead yet," and Davin would say, "Well,
you're gonna die so you might as well tell
me who did it." And as I was working the halls
of Congress, interviewing politicians and
lobbyists for environmental groups and all
those people who were trying to drive legislation,
I often thought of Davin. And I tried to resist,
for a long time, the idea of thinking about
this book as a murder mystery because climate
legislation missed a lot of near death experiences,
or survived a lot of near death experiences
in the years I was working on this book. And
I had a great deal of respect for the environmentalists
I was spending so much time with. And just
to lay it down, I spent time and established
embargoed reporting relationships with a whole
group of people from Al Gore and the Alliance
for Climate Protection to Fred Krup and the
Environmental Defense Fund to lobbyists like
the folks at the American Coalition for Clean
Coal Electricity, who are trying to keep the
world safe for coal-fired electric generation
and essentially stave off climate legislation
for as long as possible. A professional climate
denier named Myron Ebell from the Competitive
Enterprise Institute, Jim Hansen, the climatologist,
and a number of other people on various sides
of the fight right down to the activists who
are chaining themselves to bulldozers to try
to prevent the construction of coal-fired
power plants. So, I basically was a ping-pong
for three years, bouncing among all these
groups as the story unfolded. And then finally,
this summer, after I'd finished work on the
book, I wanted to close it and have it come
out in the midst of what I hoped would be
the next debate and then write the final chapters
for the second edition of book, or the paperback
edition. But this summer, here we are in the
hottest summer in recorded history, or at
least so far it's shaping up to be that, in
the hottest year in recorded history, we've
just completed the hottest decade in reported
history, which beat the record set by the
previous decade, which beat the record set
by the decade before that. We're at a moment
where the Russian wheat harvest is being decimated
by drought and unprecedented heat, hundreds
of deaths being recorded in Moscow, wildfires,
and I thought back to somebody who said to
me a few years ago, he said, "Well, when Greenland
starts falling into the sea, we'll be ready
to get serious about climate change." Well,
on August 5th, a chunk of Greenland, four
times the size of Manhattan, calved off and
fell into the sea. Ed Markey, the Congressman,
said that's ample room for the professional
deniers to set up their own country and they're
now trying to figure out what to call it.
But it is if folks need evidence that this
is going on, the evidence is all around us.
And yet, the United States Senate, just about
a week before that huge Greenland ice flow
separated from the mainland, announced that
it would not be debating comprehensive climate
legislation, that it would not be even debating
a measly 15% renewable energy standard, which
would require utilities to get that percentage
of their power from alternative means. And
I, many of you saw in the paper today, in
the New York Times, a great story about renewable
electricity in Portugal, which in the last
five years have, has moved from 17% to 45%
of its electricity from renewable sources.
Just one example of what's possible, now obviously,
the scale in this country is completely different;
much harder for us to scale up as quickly
as Portugal is doing, but at the federal level,
we're not even trying. I'll talk about things
that are going on at the state and local level
a little later. But the fact is, across three
years of repeated attempts, the US Senate
has always been a complete obstacle to action
in this area. So, as I said, it was a who-done-it
that I ended up writing. It was a murder mystery
and what I hadn't anticipated was that it
would end up being one a lot like Agatha Christie's
"Murder on the Orient Express" where there
are multiple culprits; everybody is in on
the killing. So, I thought that I would start
by talking a little bit about who some of
these culprits are and why it's been so hard
for us to achieve any kind of climate action
at the federal level.
[pause]
The first group that you have to begin with
is the professional deniers. And let me just
say, I differentiate between regular folks
who are skeptical about climate change and
don't know what to believe and the paid professional
public relations executives whose job it has
been to spread doubt and confusion about climate
change for the last 15 or 20 years. And I
mentioned Myron Ebell, one of the people that
I look at in the course of the book. These
are folks that I don't claim to have George
W. Bush's ability to look into someone's eyes
and see down into their soul the way the President
famously said he could about Putin. So, I
don't know, and I'm often asked, "Do they
really believe it? Are they just mercenaries?"
Ultimately, I don't think it matters because
I've come to the conclusion in more than 25
years of journalism that motive is highly
overrated; that ultimately, it doesn't really
matter why you're doing what you're doing.
If what you're doing is bad for the planet,
the country, the economy, the future of civilization,
the fact that I talked myself into believing
it doesn't really make that much of a difference.
So, I didn't take, make any grand attempt
to try to figure out if Myron Ebell and his
ilk believe what they were saying. And I don't
spend an enormous time in the book dealing
with science. I do, if you're not familiar
with climate science and you read The Climate
War, you will pick up an awful lot of carefully
fact-checked science about exactly what's
happening and why. But the thrust of the book
is politics and economics, because what I
found with the professional deniers is they
were more than happy to fight this war on
multiple levels for people who are still capable
of being convinced that the science is not
sound and we don't really know what's happening.
They will fight it on that level. For other
people that are sure that the science is real
and as I'm sure, all or most of you know,
the overwhelming majority of climatologists
in this country has no doubt the basics of
climate science are fundamentally understood,
have been for a hundred years, are not in
dispute. Of course, there's always debate
in any realm of science. Debate never goes
away and I actually think that Al Gore and
the environmental community made a strategic
error when they announced that the debate
was settled and it was time to move on. Because,
by refusing to engage the deniers, they seeded
the messaging space to the professional deniers,
who filled it up with this information. And
Gore and the Green Group, which is the loose
coalition of major environmental organizations
in this country, made a decision to stop arguing
about it and say, "Well now we have to move
on." Well, even though they were right, I
think it was the wrong tactic because you
all know what happened. The deniers, along
with their enablers in my line of work, the
journalists who are scared to come out and
say anything without hedging it, so they're
always looking for what climatologists say.
"This is happening, but I'm gonna get the
appearance of balance into my stories. So,
I'm gonna look for somebody who's saying 'Well,
maybe it's not really happening,' and here's
Myron Ebell, or others who share his profession,
stepping up and sowing down confusion on what
is actually established science." So, that's
what we call "balanced bias." That's elevating
two sides of an argument, even when there
aren't two co-equal sides. And that happened
with the science for many years till slowly
the journalism community began to move on
from that false opposition. And then they
began to do it with the economics, which was
the second great front in the climate war.
When the climate deniers saw that people were
no longer swayed by disinformation on the
science, they began to fill the airwaves with
disinformation on economics and they claimed
that any action to stop climate change would
destroy the American economy. They hired economists,
usually from right-wing and libertarian think
tanks to produce doomsday studies that claimed
to prove that if we capped carbon emissions
it would kill millions of jobs and double
electricity rates. And then they would find
gullible journalists who would write stories
about these without ever looking at the fine
print and seeing, "Well, what are the economic
assumptions that you're putting into these
models?" And economic assumptions, when you
looked at them, were completely bogus. Cite
one example that I cite in my book, a study
sponsored by the National Association of Manufactures
and it's assumption for uptake of wind power
year after year between now and 2030 was that
we would use, we would take less wind new
generation capacity online in each year than
we did in 2007. So that in other words, the
transition to a clean energy economy had already
peaked. And when you start cooking the numbers
that way, it's not a surprise that you get
extremely high electricity rates as your output.
So, that's what they did. When you look at
it, that's just one example, there are a lot
of others, in the fine print of all of those
studies, but the reporters wouldn't actually
ever bother to look under the hood of these
studies. They would just present the doomsday
report and I got the feeling that if somebody
affiliated with the National Association of
Manufacturers had stood up and said that in
2030, the sky will be yellow and the sun will
be blue, the headline the next day would read,
"Sun Will Be Blue Economist Warns" and they
would just put it out there. So, the press
enabled the deniers as, and I call them the
"deny and delay community" because step one
was denying climate science and step two is
delaying climate action. It was less interesting
as I hung out with the professional deniers
to see their twisted take on the science then
it was to learn about their view of the politics
because they laid out an entire playbook for
how they intended to kill climate action and
let me tell you, it worked. I think I'll read
just a couple of paragraphs from an interview
that I did with Myron Ebell of the Competitive
Enterprise Institute.
Quote:
"'Global warming is a problem that will be
easy to solve,' Ebell said. And now his little
smile was back because Ebell was in his comfort
zone again saying something counterintuitive
and outrageous." Quote "'We'll solve it in
50 years. We'll take carbon dioxide out of
the atmosphere and one one-hundred thousandths
of the cost of the solutions that Al is banding
about.' Ebell kept referring to Gore by his
first name. Al, as if they were colleagues
who were working in an atmosphere of mutual
respect, when, in fact, CEI had spent years
trying to trash and discredit Gore. It was
impossible to imagine Gore referring to Ebell
as Myron. Ebell's full-time job was to keep
alive the impression that the scientific debate
was wide open, and yet here he was conceding
that climate change was a problem, though
an easily solved one, that levels of greenhouse
gas were rising and that this would eventually
need to be addressed. It felt surprising,
but it shouldn't have. As those who tracked
him over the years had pointed out, Ebell
was always dependably opposed to climate action,
but his stance on just what was happening
to the planet seemed to morph to fit the moment.
A connoisseur might call today's formulation
'classic late period Ebell.' Spotting his
opponents, much of the scientific argument,
but still holding out against doing a damn
thing. 'I could concede a lot on the science,'
he said. I don't, but I could and I'd still
think this was the wrong way to address the
problem. The public doesn't agree with me,
though. They say if there is warming, then
we have a moral obligation to solve it. If
there's not, then we don't. As a result, he
explained those who opposed climate action
needed to dig in on the scientific details
and concede nothing." Quote "'The science
is still the battleground. The battle is still
over whether this is really happening and
whether we are really causing it.' It was
a war and Ebell could see Gore's troops massing
on the far ridge." Quote "'We want to drive
a wedge between bi-coastal, elite opinion
and heartland opinion,' he said. 'We have
to protect our base from a hundred million
dollars a year in Al Gore's advertising. I
don't think we can ever win over your typical
New Yorker or San Franciscan, but we don't
need to. This battle is for the heartland.
If we protect our base, we win.'"
So, the goal for the deniers was to protect
their base by scaring the pants off people
with these doomsday arguments; arguing that
so-called cap and tax, a national energy tax,
would destroy their household budgets and
destroy the economy and throw the mellow out
of work. And the reality is that the cap that
was being debated in the United States Senate
would have imposed costs of roughly 70 to
140 dollars a year per household by 2030.
For low income households, it was a net plus.
There were rebates that would actually make
sure that low income Americans came out ahead.
So, the idea that this was gonna be an onerous
burden was simply not true, but that didn't
stop the opponents of climate action from
putting out their false reports and it didn't
solve the Senate Republicans from picking
up that rallying cry. And they were the second
group responsible for killing the climate
bill, where the Senate Republicans who opposed
climate action to a man. There wasn't a single
senator and a woman, a single man or woman
in the United States Republican Caucus this
year who was willing to come forward in support
of climate action. We look back now on 2008,
2007, even 2005 as the good old days of bi-partisanship
on this issue. When you had John McCain as
the leading proponent of climate action in
the US Senate, more recently with a conservative
primary challenge, McCain stopped talking
about it and then did a flip-flop and called
the senate bill based on the bill that McCain
himself had co-sponsored years ago, a farce
and said he wouldn't support it. His mantle
of republican climate courage was adopted
by Lindsey Graham, the South Carolina Republican
who tried to hammer out a climate bill for
about ten months between 2009 and 2010 and
then jumped ship the weekend before they were
set to unveil the bill. He did this for a
couple of reasons. He was getting completely
hammered by his own party and he had come
to the conclusion that the Senate Democrats
weren't serious about trying to move a bill
this year. What led him to that? Well, the
fact was they weren't serious. The Senate
Majority Leader, Harry Reid, decided that
he was gonna try to curry favor with Latino
voters by pretending that he was gonna move
an immigration bill instead of a climate bill.
When he signaled that, even thought there
was no immigration bill written, and there
was a climate bill waiting to move, that was
a pretty good indication that the Senate was
just playing politics and wasn't ever really
gonna try to pass a bill. Now, it was in the
interest of all the Democrats to go through
the motions. Now some of them wanted to do
it but the will of the Senate was not there.
And the only guy getting hammered over this
was Lindsey Graham, so he said, "Why should
I stick my head up out of the fox hole here
and take friendly fire from my own party if
the Democrats aren't really gonna try to do
this?" So he jumped ship. So, after you've
got the Senate Republicans as being culprits,
you've gotta add the Senate Democrats to the
list of people who are in on this murder because
the truth is Harry Reid never had the juice
to try to lead his committee chairmen to actually
move a bill. And the committee chairmen, with
the exception of Barbara Boxer and John Kerry,
were not serious about trying to do it. I
mentioned that every Republican in the Senate
was opposed to climate action. There were
a few, like Olympia Snowe and Susan Collins,
who probably would have come on board had
there been an actual bill. And the Democrats,
after everything crashed and burned were quick
to blame the Republicans as being the guilty
party, ignoring the dozen or so Midwestern
Democrats who were also opposed to climate
action. These were not all from the Midwest,
but largely from the Midwest, from coal-burning
states; from states that either mine and produce
coal or states that depend on coal for their
electric fired electricity, excuse me, their
coal-fired electricity. So, there are 25 states
in the US that get 25%--I'm sorry, 50% or
more of their electricity from coal. And it's
hard to tell whether those Democratic Senators
are really worried about the effect on the
economy of a climate bill, which they say
they worried about, or whether they're just
worried about the effect on their re-elections
if they support climate action. Because, as
I said, all of the best studies show that
the economic effect of climate action, especially
the very modest, early step that's being debated
in the Senate, would be minimal. What wouldn't
be minimal was the force of the attack on
the politicians if they supported this. And
so, these people were scared; I believe more
of the politics than they were of the economics.
And they realized, I think, how difficult
this was gonna be in the summer of 2008, when
the Lieberman-Warner bill crashed and burned
in the United States Senate. They realized
that again, in the summer of 2009, at the
moment of the greatest success for the climate
movement, when the Waxman-Markey bill passed
the House of Representatives by a very narrow
margin, but it did pass. The first time that
either house of Congress had ever passed a
major landmark piece of climate legislation.
And what happened after that scared the pants
off the US Senate because as soon as that
bill passed and the environmental groups that
had been pushing it and the Coalition of Environmental
and Fortune 500 groups called USCAP that had
helped write the bill, and had been instrumental
in pushing it through; a signature moment
of compromise between environmental America
and corporate America coming together to try
to get something done. They got it passed,
they all took a breather and it was a big
mistake because that was the moment when the
opposition to climate action unleashed the
full fury of its opposition. That was the
rise of the Tea Party Movement; started on
the 4th of July, 2009. Obviously there had
been some Tea Party demonstrations around
tax day in the spring, but if you recall,
the 4th of July demonstrations, just a little
over a year ago now, unspooled an enormous
amount of fury at all of the politicians,
especially the eight Republicans who had voted
in favor of that bill and swing state Democrats.
There were expensive advertising that came
on the air immediately targeting those courageous
politicians. There was the full rage and fury
of Rush Limbaugh and Glen Beck and every other
right-wing commentator on the airwaves and
it essentially caught the climate action community
flatfooted. It terrified the US Senate and
it even led the political strategists inside
the West Wing of the White House to think
that maybe this was gonna be too hard to do.
So, there was a climate bill, it had passed
the house, it was ready to steam on toward
the Senate with some important modifications
to be made to get it to 60 and the White House
and the Senate decided not even to try to
move that bill. The White House was pushing
what was described to me by multiple Obama
advisors as a quote "stealth strategy" toward
moving climate policy that would deploy the
President only sparingly. It would deploy
him, usually on a weekday afternoon on a visit
to a solar factory or wind turbine factory,
where he would say all the right things about
the need to accelerate the transition to clean
energy. He would talk about the need to cap
carbon, he would say all the right things
when the country wasn't listening, but for
the first 18 months of his administration,
he did not make a single prime time address
calling for this. There was one shining moment
in the first address to the joint session
of Congress, what we usually call the State
of the Union, but in the first year of the
president, president's term, it's not a State
of the Union address, it's just called the
Joint Address. So, that was a moment when
he said he'd wanted Congress to send him a
bill that capped carbon. He never devoted
an entire speech to the issue until after
the BP spill that forced his hand and Obama
wanted to change the subject from the oil
spill to climate and energy. I mean, he wanted
to change it to anything he could and the
logical place to go was the need to get off
oil. So, he began talking about it a little
bit in June and July, and he scheduled an
Oval Office address, maybe some of you saw
it, where he sat down and he explained what
the country was doing to cope with the oil
spill and he explained that this was yet another
reason to get off fossil fuels. And then instead
of saying, "And we know how to do it. We need
to put a cap on carbon emissions. We need
to price carbon so that clean energy becomes
economically competitive and profitable."
The President said, "We don't know how we're
gonna get there." He didn't use the word cap.
He didn't come out in favor of a specific
piece of legislation and hearts sank throughout
the climate and clean energy community that
night because it became clear that the President
was not going to be driving a particular piece
of legislation, even though what was being
called the worst environmental disaster in
American history gave him a perfect opportunity
to do that. He felt that it was gonna be too
hard. He felt that he had already asked the
United States Senate to do enough; tap into
their political capital with difficult votes
for the stimulus bill and healthcare reform
bill and the bailouts of the auto industry,
etc. So, he wasn't willing to try again and
so, when the President would have members
of the White House to talk about climate and
energy legislation, they would leave, he would
not make a comment, they would step up the
microphones and say they had had a wonderful
exchange of views and nothing specific would
come out. So, the final culprit is the President
of the United States. And I didn't really
expect when I began a book called "The Climate
War," that one of those wars would be unfolding
inside the West Wing of the White House, but
that's what I discovered. There were people
in the White House, notably Rahm Emmanuel,
the Chief of Staff and David Axelrod, the
Chief Strategist, who felt that the public
was not in a place where they were ready for
the President to make this a signature agenda
item. He could talk about it, he could play
to his base, he could do the Tuesday at the
Vestas Wind Turbine Facility, but in prime
time when it counted, and certainly when he
was campaigning, heading into a mid-term election
was not the time to do it. So, in retrospect,
2009 was our window of opportunity. This is
no surprise. In my book I describe Al Gore
sending a memo President Obama in the first
days of the Obama Administration laying out
exactly why it was important for the President
to get behind a mandatory declining cap. In
2009, why the, why it had to be the first
big agenda item after he finished the economy,
not kicked down the road, mainly because the
countries of the world were meeting in December
of 2009 in Copenhagen, to hammer out a successor
to the Kyoto Treaty and if the United States
came up empty handed, showed up in Copenhagen
empty handed without a bill to reduce emissions,
the global deal was gonna crash and burn.
That's what Gore warned Obama about and that's
precisely what happened in December of 2009.
So, where are we now? We haven't done the
hard work. We're about to experience a mid-term
election where votes for climate action will
probably go away. Could it have been any different
and what we can we do over the next few years?
I think in 2009, if Obama had surveyed the
landscape after the Waxman-Markey bill passed,
but then ran into that buzz saw of opposition.
And he had said at that time, an economy wide
cap is gonna be too hard. We've gotta lead
a tactical retreat to just a cap on the utility
sector, which makes up 40% of the emissions
in this country." It's a great place to begin.
We've already got a cap on sulfur dioxide--the
pollution that causes acid rain-- it was passed.
And the Clear Act Amendments of 1990, it went
into effect in 1995, it has reduced that pollution
ahead of schedule and below cost. It's been
a huge win. The utility sector knows how to
regulate its smokestacks. EPA knows what to
do. Let's start there and let's take the next
year to get it done. Let's get everybody around
the table and figure out how to do this. I
think we'd be celebrating a victory; a first
small step now instead of yet another defeat.
The climate action community, the Green Group,
was not willing to take that stand because
they were so invested in a mandatory economy-wide
cap, they weren't willing to retreat. It would
have required presidential leadership to get
that done. And the President didn't stake
that claim, he did not lead on that, he did
not lay out a vision for something that was
achievable given the difficult economic and
political situation of 2009 and 10, and as
a result, we didn't get it done; anything
at all. In the last few weeks, before the
Senate pulled the plug on the bill, they tried
to beat a retreat to that utility-only place,
but it was too late, it was too complicated,
they couldn't get it done in the short period
of time that they had at hand. It may be the
place to begin when we start with a new Senate
after the elections. It may be possible to
just start there, but in fact, my hunch is
gonna be that we're not gonna be able to even
address that for a couple of years. I think
we're going into a period now and I hate to
say it and I have avoided making apocalyptic
predictions, but right now it looks like this
is where we are. If we're gonna be losing
votes and we weren't even close to 60 for
an economy-wide cap, I think it's gonna be
tough to get to 60 for the next year or two
and I think we need to change the math a little
bit, we need to change the politics a little
bit, we need to put some points on the boards.
We need to, in other words, reduce emissions
without having a mandatory cap for awhile
and then come back to the idea. In Copenhagen,
when it was crashing and burning, I sat with
Al Gore and I asked him, "What happens if
we can't pass this bill in 2010?" And he said,
"Well, if the Senate refuses to act or the
climate bill fails or is watered down beyond
recognition," he said, "that's an event horizon
beyond which it's almost impossible to see."
He said, "It may mean there's a fundamental
flaw in the architecture of the political
solution. But the problem," he said, "is that
we don't have a plan B. When it comes to reducing
emissions, there's really not a lot of alternative
to reducing emissions. That's what you need
to do." So, there's the cap, there's the idea
of a tax. The politics of a carbon tax are
just as fraught as the politics of a carbon
cap. So, what we need to do is shut-up the
Chicken Littles, who say that we can't reduce
emissions, by reducing them for a while. And
we have a lot to build on. Emissions had been
declining in this country and not just because
of the recession. In the great state of Texas,
a governor named George W. Bush, passed a
mandatory renewable energy standard, a renewable
electricity standard in, I believe the year
was 2009 that it took effect. It's now been
taking effect, it's now been in effect for
a decade and it has helped give birth to the
Texas wind industry, which has created something
like ten thousand jobs. It has created ten
gigawatts of wind-powered electric generation
and it has helped reduce emissions in the
great state of Texas. They have not done this
because they're worried about climate change.
They've done this because energy is what Texas
does and they see a market and they see a
opportunity to make money. But they've reduced
emissions anyway. So, again, remember I said
motive is overrated? Any reason that anyone
has for getting into the game and reducing
emissions, I'm all for. That's why it's such
a tragedy that the Senate wouldn't put a renewable
energy standard into its energy bill. Of course,
now it's pulled the plug on the bill itself.
It says they're gonna come back to it in the
fall, but they fail to see that what we need
in this country is a market. What we need
to do is level the playing field for clean
electric generation so it can compete against
dirty electric generation. It's not a difficult
concept to understand. There are a lot of
different ways to do it and we may be able
to experiment with some other ways before
we get back to a cap at the federal level.
That's why it's so important now that the
western front in the climate war is unfolding
now in California with an attempt to roll
back a bill called AB 32, which made California
the first state in the country, excuse me,
yeah, the first state in the United States
to put a mandatory declining cap on statewide
emissions. People wanna roll that back now.
There's a ballot initiative that's being bankrolled
by two Texas oil companies and that is a huge
battle. The second battle is gonna unfold
in the United States Senate when senators
try to strip the EPA of its authority to regulate
greenhouse gases. Remember back, I said in
2007, I thought the politics were shifting,
that the debate was shifting from science
to economics? One of the things that led me
to believe that was the Supreme Court decision.
The Supreme Court of the United States held
that the EPA had the duty to decide whether
carbon emissions posed a threat to public
health and that if it did, then it had the
obligation to regulate. EPA has since made
that determination and is scheduled to roll
out regulation beginning in January of next
year. The Senate is gonna try to strip EPA
of that power. And depending on what happens
to the balance of power in the Senate, it
could be a very close vote. That's incredibly
important because the Senate has made it clear
that it isn't gonna act on this issue anytime
soon. So, what the Senate is saying is, "We
wanna reserve the right to do nothing on this
issue. We want the perogatives of power to
be reserved for the United States Senate so
that we cannot act." Ok, we wanna prevent
the United States from doing this. Now this
is an area where I know that President Obama
is gonna be throwing his considerable might
into turning back at any attempt to roll back
EPA. And I hope very much that the attempt
to strip EPA of those powers, or delay their
implementation, will be defeated just as two
previous attempts this year have already been
turned back. However, EPA regulation is what
John Dingell, the veteran Congressman from
Michigan, once described as "the glorious
mess." It is gonna be a glorious mess of regulation,
which is going to lead to litigation. Why
is that? Because the only way the EPA can
regulate is to do so on a source by source
basis, power plant by power plant, factory
by factory. So, there's gonna be lawsuits
around every stationary source of emissions.
In other words, we are moving from a moment
of attempted legislative compromise between
the environmental community, the regulatory
community and the corporate world into a period
of renewed battling between those entities.
Environmental organizations that had been
putting their money in their manpower into
finding a compromise in Congress are now pulling
back and they're putting their manpower into
the courts. They're going back to suing the
bastards to shut down the dirtiest power plants.
There are 153 coal-fired power plants east
of the Mississippi that were built in the
50s and 60s that are terrible sources of pollution
and extremely inefficient and they should
be shut down tomorrow. And the EPA will be
rolling out its draft regulations in September
for implementation beginning in January and
it is devoutly to be wished that some of these
most polluting plants are not gonna be able
to meet EPA standards and will have to be
shut down finally. The whole search for a
compromise in the Congress and the whole reason
for a cap was to reduce rate shocks and regulatory
costs on industry, on the utility industry
and the manufacturing industry so that they
could find ways to smooth out their costs
by trading carbon permits between various
emitting entities. It was a compromise that,
as I mentioned earlier, was very successful
when it was used for sulfur dioxide. It was
a compromise championed by Republican President
George H. W. Bush, and then it was demonized
by the current Republican Party and turned
into a crazy left-wing scheme and Enron Rube
Goldberg contraption, a way to put the investment
bankers in charge of climate action. You saw
what the attacks leveled on, what were actually,
what was actually a centrist approach, was
vilified as being a kooky left-wing, Al Gore,
eco-hoax to seize control of the energy economy.
And as a result of the success of those attacks,
they're now right back to EPA command and
control regulation of the kind that they wanted
to avoid in the first place. So, it's gonna
be ugly for a couple years, folks. And my
hope is that a couple of years of bitter battling
in the courts between the environmental groups,
the corporations, and the EPA will make everyone
wake up and smell the coffee that there's
a better way forward here. And maybe those
groups will then go back into the legislative
arena and that the Republican Party and the
conservative wing of the Democratic Party
will agree that it's time to actually get
serious. And maybe when that happens, I'll
be able to write a happy ending to my book,
The Climate War. So, with that, I'd like to
open the floor to questions.
[applause]
>>Male member #1: Just started reading your
book on the iPad; kudos to your publisher
for getting it there. Your writing style is
quite engaging and informative.
>>Eric: Thank you.
>>member #1: I guess you've been doing it
a long time, so, but you seem to be preaching
to the converted. So, I wonder how you picked
a side and what you would say to someone who
view you, who views you the way you view those
you call deniers, as somebody who might be
sincere, but is profoundly mistaken on the
science?
>>Eric: Fair question. The, as I say, I don't,
I reserve the term deniers for the paid professionals
whose job it is to sow doubt and confusion
about climate change. I use the word skeptics
for everyday folks who are skeptical about
whether it's happening and I hope that my
book. I'm delighted that you find my writing
style engaging, my mother does too and I hope
that it's engaging to people who are confused
or in doubt about what's going on. But as
I set out to write the book, I decided that
I couldn't pretend that there were two equal
sides here. I couldn't write a book that said,
"Well, some people say this is happening and
some people say it's not." I felt that that
would be intellectually dishonest. It's not
what I believe. I have been looking very,
very closely at the evidence, the scientific
evidence for climate change and I find the
evidence overwhelming. I find it extremely
compelling and I think that people who take
a fair look at what's happening, and the weight
of evidence that's described in my book and
many others, will be lead to that same conclusion.
That said, there are people, roughly a quarter
to a third of the country according to the
polls, who aren't sure it's happening or don't
think it's happening. And I am, I'm not here
to call you a denier or to question your motives.
I think there are people of, as I say in the
book, and maybe you haven't gotten to this
part yet, people of goodwill who don't think
this is happening. That said, there are plenty
of books out there that explain what's happening
and why. And I didn't feel that what I brought
to the party would necessarily be another
book about climate science. There are some
great ones. A good one by a climatologist
named Heidi Cullen, called "The Weather of
the Future," just came out last week. Jim
Hansen's "Storms of my Grandchildren" is another
one; there are a lot of terrific books. So,
I didn't feel that what I wanted to do was
write another book about climate science.
I'm a political reporter and a business editor
and I wanted to write about the intersection
of politics and economics and write about
the argument over getting this done. So, so
my book I guess, is for people that think
it's real and wonder why it's so hard to take
action because there are valid economic arguments
that need to be addressed. In my view, the
climate policy has moved a lot further than
the climate politics and the policies have
actually figured out how to cushion Americans
from rising electricity rates, for example,
how to cushion carbon intensive industries
from competition with non-carbon constrained
economies. So, I think we know what to do;
we just lack the political will to do it.
If you are a climate skeptic and you're feeling
left out of my book, I would say you might
stick with it and it might bring you around,
or you could always, I don't know.
[laughter]
I hope that my argument is compelling enough
that it can turn some people's minds and I
know that, in fact, it has turned a few because
I've been hearing from some people. But that
said, I don't claim to be a magician and if
you don't find the arguments compelling, then
I would urge you to go deeper into the science
because I think the science is compelling.
>>member #1: Thank you.
>>Eric: Yes, sir.
>>Male member #2: Well, that was actually
a rather depressing talk. I guess I sit here
thinking, "What can we do?" And the only thing
that came to mind was, well maybe if the Internet
does put every single current journalist onto
the unemployment line, that'll be a good thing.
But I guess I have one specific question.
You didn't talk at all about international
politics. My sense is that I hear a lot of
arguing with reform, unless the Chinese and
the Indians do this also, then anything we
do is pointless and hurts us. And you either
hear that argument in completely different
contexts, like health and safety regulations.
So, is that important or is Congress so focused
on inside the beltway that it doesn't really
matter?
>>Eric: That's incredibly important and it's
a very important argument and I'm glad you
brought it up. My book opens in Bali at the
International Climate Negotiations there and
it closes in Copenhagen with an afterword
that takes the story up through the most recent
Senate bill. So, international negotiation
is incredibly important. The truth is that
until the United States acts, a global deal
is not possible. So, the global deal is not
waiting on China; the global deal is waiting
on us. And the argument that we shouldn't
act until China and India act is completely
misinformed for a couple of reasons. Now,
lemme not sound like I'm just rejecting it
out of hand, I understand the fears of competing
with China and I understand the fears of people
who are worried that their jobs are gonna
be exported to China. The trouble here is
that we're trying to legislate via the rear
view mirror. We're trying to save 20th century
manufacturing jobs instead of worrying about
developing 21st century jobs. The fact is
that China is stealing our bacon in the clean
energy race. China is already receiving twice
as much venture capital money in clean energy
as the United States. In the second quarter
of 2010, it received more venture capital
funding than the US and Europe combined. So,
money is flooding into China. And why is it
flooding into China? Because they have a market.
Why do they have a market? Because a centralized
authoritarian government that plans the economy
has decreed that they'll have a market and
is spending nine billion dollars a month in
public money to make sure that clean energy
is incented. They are expecting to spend upwards
of 300 billion dollars on clean energy in
the People's Republic over the next decade.
That's just public money. So, we can't compete
with that level of spending. We need a market
to pull our private dollars off the sidelines.
And so, the real international argument, or
international competition that we oughta be
talking about is the race to dominate the
clean energy economy, which we are badly losing
to China now. Item two, today's New York Times,
China is closing 2,087 of its dirtiest, most
polluting factories by decree on September
1st, I believe the date is. So, that's more
than two thousand of their dirtiest plants,
which is gonna have a serious reduction in
their carbon intensity; it's not gonna get
them all the way to their targets. But the
idea that China is not acting is an obsolete
argument. China is acting in ways that we
can't. In fact, the very day that the Senate
announced that it wasn't gonna be debating
a climate bill, China announced that they're
putting into place a carbon trading program.
So, the day that we said we're not gonna have
one, they said, "We're gonna experiment with
one." So, China is moving ahead. But there's
an important distinction between China and
the US. The US had a one century or more head
start over China and India in developing our
prosperity through a carbon-based economy.
It would be unfair for us to expect China
to get into the game on the exact same timetable
that we're doing. So, the notion that we oughta
wait for China to act, and in fact, the idea
that China and India don't have to act is
entwined in the international treaties. They
are part of the developing world, which is
not required in the Kyoto Treaty to reduce
emissions. We're part of the developed world,
which is required. We, alone among the developed
world, refused to sign, refused to ratify
the treaty. So, I like the statement that
was made by Republican Senator John Warner,
co-sponsor of the Lieberman-Warner climate
bill in 2008, when he said, "We can't allow
China and India to hide behind our skirts
of inaction." Ok, if we, if we continue not
to act, we continue to give them a reason
not to act. In fact, China has proven that
they wanna dominate clean energy; they're
number one in wind energy production, number
one in solar PbC production. They are moving
ahead with their low-cost manufacturing advantages
as well as their huge government pushed market.
I think it's probably already too late for
us to beat them at the clean energy race,
but we can at least stay in the game. And
in order to do that, we need to price carbon
and we need to put in place renewable energy
standards and do a lot of other policies;
all of which we know what to do, we just need
the political will to do them. Yes, sir.
>>Male member #3: Two short questions. The
first is how much is the failure to pass action
related to the economic collapse and the specter
of job loss potentially being so unpopular
in this time with people being out of work?
And the second short part there is, you think
it'd be easier to, instead of raising the
cost of carbon to lower the cost of clean
energy through rebates? Is that more politically,
more political will behind that than maybe
capping carbon?
>>Eric: Two good questions. The, I'll start
with the lower of the cost of clean energy.
I'm all for that and it's gonna take R&D and
deployment money to do that as well. And,
the question is what's the funding mechanism
to actually put the billions and billions
of dollars into that that we would need to
make a real dent in it? The nice thing about
the cap is that it gives you a revenue stream
and you can spend that revenue stream on intensive
R&D, and you're not just raising the cost
of fossil fuels, you're also lowering the
cost of clean energy. But should we do that?
Yeah, we should start by getting rid of the
subsidies for fossil fuels, which are still
a subsidized energy source in this country,
and I think that's still globally. There's
a lot of disinformation from fossil fuel companies
saying, "Well, we can't just give clean energy
all these subsidies and artificially reduce
the price." But we've been artificially reducing
the price of petroleum for generations in
this country and, in fact, we've never priced
in the social cost of petroleum, the cost
of the pollution, the cost of oil spills,
the cost of climate change; none of those
costs are factored into the cost of carbon
since spewing carbon is free. So, the first
step would be to close that loophole and put
into place what the opponents call attacks,
what's really just a common sense fee. It's
a common sense pollution fee. If I wanna go
down to the dump and dump all the stuff in
my garage down at my local landfill, I have
to pay to do that. So, I don't think of that
as a tax, I think of that as a use fee. So,
I do think that I'm all for reducing the cost
of clean energy through subsidies, incentives,
rebates, what have you, but I think in these
constrained times, we need a revenue stream
to do that with. To your first question, yeah,
one of the culprits was clearly the greatest
economic downturn in 70 years; one of the
reasons this was so hard to do. The Waxman-
Markey bill passing the House in the summer
of 2009 was proof that it didn't have to prevent
climate action, but it certainly made it much
harder to do. And it's ironic because, in
reality, a cap would, although it does have
a short-term economic impact, it would have
a long-term impact that would be a, that would
put us on a higher growth path. So, there's
actually an economic argument for constraining
carbon and the, that equation is understood
all the way to the top of the Obama Economic
Council. Larry Summers, in conversations with
environmentalists and Fortune 500 executives
last year, described the economic approach
as a scissors. The first blade of the scissors
would be the stimulus bill, which had 70 or
80 billion dollars just for clean energy deployment.
The second blade of the scissors would be
the cap, which would bring all of this private
money off the sidelines and create an enormous
incentive and unleash innovation and pick
up where the stimulus bill left off. But,
the sad thing is that our scissors is short
one blade, right? So, we're trying to cut
but we're not really getting it done. And
I think this'll be the last question. Can
we have time for one more?
>>presenter female: No, unfortunately we don't--
>>Eric: Sorry about that.
>>presenter female: thank you for coming.
>>Eric: Thank you everybody. I appreciate
it.
[applause]